Why are we always getting involved in everyone
else's trouble because we're the
freaking Guardians of the Galaxy
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie I had a chance
to see Guardians of the Galaxy 3 so this will be
my review video be sure to go see it as soon as
possible do not wait if you're new to the channel
we're doing a giveaway for movie tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and post
your favorite Guardians moment from any of the
Marvel movies so far I will do a full post credit
scene video and breakdown for the entire movie
with all the Easter eggs later next week after
the movie is released everywhere and do stay after
the credits there are post-credit scenes we are
talking about Marvel movies here if you remember
there were five post credit scenes after Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 so in this movie they're back down
to a normal number of post-credit scenes but there
is so much stuff that we have to talk about so
don't worry like my full breakdown Easter eggs
video will be very very long when I post it next
week I was really happy to find out the movie was
as good as I hoped it would be Marvel really
needed to hit on their hands right now just
with all the shellacking they've taken the last
several months it went way beyond my expectations
just based on all the other Marvel movies I'd had
such high hopes for Ant-Man the WASP quantumania
with King the Conqueror after seeing him in the
Loki series as he who remains knowing it was going
to be the beginning of Marvel phase five and they
kept billing it as this mini Avengers movie like
Captain America Civil War so you were really hyped
going into it Marvel wanting to set up Avengers 5
King Dynasty in a way that they hadn't really done
during Marvel phase four but the difference with
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is that it had so much
to do just beyond that like in addition to being a
good movie on its own and setting up future movies
and being the last movie in a Trilogy and wrapping
up all these different character arcs and there
are many Guardians of the Galaxy it's not like
they're just like two characters there's a bunch
of them so there's a ton of story lines that you
have to wrap up several of the cast members have
gone on record saying it's their last Marvel movie
ever or at least they think that it's their
last Marvel movie ever the last time playing
the character even though I think some of them
are being kind of misleading because we do have
Avengers Secret Wars and pretty much anybody
who's ever even thought about being a Marvel
character is probably going to be in that movie
even the ones from the fox Marvel Universe in the
Sony Marvel Universe but the movie succeeded on
pretty much all the different fronts that it had
to succeed on like it was a good movie on its own
just a self-contained movie if you just wandered
into it and you hadn't seen the other Guardians
of the Galaxy movies before this it also did a
decent job of setting up other future movies not
just Avengers 5 King Dynasty Avengers Secret Wars
but other future teasers for characters that they
can pay off in potential future movies and it did
a great job of wrapping up everyone's character
arcs that started in the first movie when I
talk about setting out future movies though you
have to imagine that all the Marvel movies have
to function like a glorified television series
serialize setting up a much larger story that they
pay off in big bookends Avengers movies but for
example one of the differences nowadays is that
Disney recently just backtracked on doing infinite
sequels in same franchises so don't expect anybody
else to get a fourth movie ever except Spider-Man
any movie that earns over a billion dollars is
going to get as many sequels as it wants James
Gunn does use some of the movie to help set up
different characters that Marvel can continue in
future movies Adam Warlock probably the biggest
one of all I feel like this not a spoiler to talk
about him because it's in all the trailers he's
meant to be kind of like the vision of the movie
This Ultra powerful perfect being who feels like
he was just born yesterday and is still trying
to figure out good from evil in his own sense of
morality but the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts there are a couple brand new characters like
that in the movie that you haven't seen before in
other Marvel movies that they could potentially
pay off in the future so in that way there are
some seeds that James Gunn plants that Marvel can
grow later on if they want he basically said that
this is his last Marvel movie because he's running
DC films now and he's doing DC chapter one so
all of his attention is going to be going to that
after this movie comes out in theaters so we kind
of had to wrap everything up that he'd ever wanted
to do like do everything that he wanted to do and
just hope that maybe Marvel will pay off some of
these lesser things in the background but for the
most part those things are just light teases and
implied future stories they don't hijack the story
or anything like that the real story of the movie
is all about rocket and dealing with trauma
I guess in the way that all Guardians of the
Galaxy movies are about dealing with past traumas
and learning to accept yourself as you are James
Gunn actually talked about this recently I think
a volume one as being about the mother volume two
is about the father and volume 3 is about the self
and coming to terms with each of those situations
and the first one Peter Quill is coming to terms
with his relationship with his mother which is the
person he loved the most in the world in volume 2
he's coming to terms with this relationship with
his father the one he thought he wanted wasn't
the one he wanted and the one he had was better
than what he thought he was and then in the third
one it's about getting to accept yourself who are
we really and how are we okay you know mantis
even says is it one time in the in the movie
most of them don't like themselves very much
they all have issues with themselves nebula
has issues with herself Peter Quill has issues
with himself mantis they craglin they all do and
um and and Rocket most of all so I think that
that's what this this movie is about above and
beyond anything else doing everything he can
to make you cry in his Marvel movies in the
movie they use Rocket's backstory with the high
evolutionary whose whole thing is literally trying
to create the perfect life form by experimenting
changing people like turning an innocent baby
raccoon who's not bothering anyone into the
rocket that you see now against his will during
the trailer he has that line where he says High
evolutionary didn't want to make things perfect
he just hated the way things were and it's all
about that idea that you're perfect the way you
are you don't need to change yourself to be better
nebula's storyline is a big parallel for this with
Thanos like she talked about in the previous
Marvel movies her father ripped out her body
parts every time she failed or she lost a battle
to try and make her a more effective fighter to
try and make her better so a big part of her Arc
has been learning to accept herself even though I
do feel like rocket is the star of this movie like
it's an ensemble so all the actors do an amazing
job but really rocket is the secret protagonist of
all Guardians movies but like I said because James
Gunn had to wrap up all the character story arcs
he has to pay off that storyline that's been going
on with Peter Quill in the new version of Gamora
from 2014 drax's storyline since the first movie
mantis even Groot storyline Bradley Cooper did an
amazing job even though for him it's just a voice
over performance I feel like he's always done a
pretty awesome job with rocket there are three
different different actors playing rocket in this
movie though one is baby rocket another is younger
rocket and then Bradley Cooper plays the adult
version of Rocket the difference with a character
like Groot because Vin Diesel voices all the
versions of the character is that because he says
so few words they just modulate his voice to make
it sound like a younger Voice or slightly older
when he was Teenage Groot and now he's the adult
version of Groot so they don't have to change it
at all we do get the rest of Rocket's backstory
High evolutionary was the being who created him
his father so to speak there's some comic book
changes to the characters backstories in the way
that they change all the comic book stories for
the Marvel movies but everybody did a great job
most of them thinking that it would be their final
Marvel movie or at least playing it like it was
their last Marvel movie I think we will see some
of these people during Secret Wars Chris Pratt Zoe
Saldana Karen Gillen even Vin Diesel is Groot
you'd think they'd be harder for Vin Diesel to
portray Groot as a character who only speaks one
word but if you've seen any of the other versions
of Groot in any of the other Marvel movies during
different ages this Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is
probably Vin Diesel's and groot's best movie best
portrayal of Groot on screen and best performance
by Vin Diesel as Groot in a movie he's like
the gigachad version of Groot in this movie
I'm sure there'll be a lot of talk about Will
Poulter as Adam Warlock after the movie comes
out he understood the assignment I feel like he
did a pretty solid job I'm excited to see what
he does with the character in the future he's got
so much potential there'll probably be some minor
complaints from people who aren't happy with the
actor that they pick for Adam Warlock or the way
they portray him in the movie Them visioning him
during the movie portraying him as a character
who was born yesterday they do use the character
for a lot of comedy in the same way that they use
vision for comedy because he was born yesterday
and so powerful chukwudi awuji was great as the
high evolutionary you probably remember him from
James Gunn's Peacemaker series it was actually
his performance during Peacemaker that convinced
James Gunn to use him as the high evolutionary
and even though most of the movie takes place in
space it didn't feel quite as crazy as Ant-Man
and the WASP quansomania did with how unreal
the environments got it was isn't a CG mess
kind of like quantumania was and one of the other
coolest things I think is it felt like James Gunn
read everyone's complaints about the Guardians
movies not being as hardcore as they could have
been after the first one and crank the dial up
to 11 because this was his last Guardians movie
like truly going out as spectacularly as possible
holding nothing back no joke the movie could have
been rated R like it feels like it was almost
rated R that's how traumatizing it will be in
the theaters in a good way though like you will
cry be prepared to cry but it isn't meant to be
the end of the Guardians of the Galaxy team like
they might not do guardians 4 as a movie but the
Guardians of the Galaxy team will come back in
a future Marvel movie with a different roster
at some point probably Secret Wars maybe some
other Marvel movies too some are saying this is
the best Marvel movie since Avengers end game I
don't know if I'm ready to jump that far without
another re-watch or two like I have to see the
movie A couple more times but it's definitely
top three since Avengers end game and without
doing a complete re-ranking of all the Marvel
movies this is at least in my new top 5 Marvel
movies of all time I'll probably do a new Marvel
movie tier list soon just because it's been so
long since I've done one if you did hate the
previous Guardians of the Galaxy movies though
or if you just hate all Marvel movies in general
like some people just do not like comic book
movies the movie isn't going to completely turn
you around 180. as you would expect though the
music is totally on point James Gunn does not mess
around when it comes to Guardians of the Galaxy
music I believe it's actually online now I think
you can actually listen to most of the songs that
are in the movie overall just coming out of it it
came off so well it makes me way more optimistic
about the future of DC movies under James Gunn
once you watch the movie you will see that this
dude just gets it you will feel way better about
the Superman Legacy movie after this like oh yeah
maybe he can do a really good job with Superman
once you do have a chance to see the movie post
your reactions in the comments and please don't
post spoilers if you do get to see it early like I
said I will do a full post credit scene video full
breakdown Easter eggs videos for the movie after
it comes out next week we can talk about all the
spoilers during that because there is a lot a
lot of stuff that we have to talk about during
the movie overall I feel like was a great movie it
was really happy with the way it went down Marvel
definitely did need a hit right now and even
though I have no idea what the box office is
going to wind up being there are many different
factors that go into how movies box office does
the movie itself is solid because this week was
Cinemacon there was like a trailer Fest there's
still several videos that I'm working on I'll
try to post everything as quickly as possible
congratulations to the giveaway winner from my
last Marvel video adsman jays please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can get your
contact details everyone click here for all my
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 videos and click here
for my new Ahsoka trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!